buried on the death chart and left for
dead this blue jean babies fix into
scam according to my calculations it's
time to kick some
ass they were never the first choice but
they are the last hope we're losing
starters at an unprecedented
rate I will struggle at first but they
ultimately Avant you I call it operation
playoff birth the mission manage the
game and minimize turnovers
ohid it can be done now these Hired Guns
are back up and running it's a suicide
mission but there's one thing I've
learned it's better to die a starter
than live as a
backup what you got
kid time to let this cat out of the
bag yeah I'm thinking I'm
black this AOC doesn't pass bills I pass
bombs
no no no you can't make me come on Zach
we got to get I said
no I got a guy who can take care of a
thing hey forget about
[Music]
it this December the B team is the a te
oh yeah we going to eat that w we going
to sting like a butterfly and pop like a
weasel we going to go hold on to your
Bridges we got to make one more stop so
will you join you guys no I'm a leading
MVP candidate the beat
team and sometimes the C team oh sorry
dos you're
[Music]
out it's impossible I can't get you to
the playoffs playoffs huh I just need
you to get us to 500 ooh that's tough
too damn it it's my whole thing my Tom
gets a winning record so just win two
games
two